and you're gonna kill me
[Applause]
[Music]
princess Charlotte lives her best life
at King Charles's coronation concert I
think for princess Charlotte we really
see her taking after her mother case you
know she's so composed so put together
over 20 000 people were in attendance at
the special event honoring the new king
including the eight-year-old who was
joined by her big brother George and
their parents Kate Middleton and Prince
William notably missing little bro
five-year-old Louis little Louie he's
only five and it's way past his bedtime
and he had a pretty busy day yesterday
the night was full of performances that
got Charlotte and George on their feet
including Lionel Richie's all night long
[Music]
in the same way that William always had
his wingman in Harry I think it's rather
wonderful that that is being echoed here
with George and Charlotte you know
you're going to see I think real
teamwork at place here then when
Lionel's fellow American Idol judge Katy
Perry took the stage Charlotte proved
she's a kitty cat singing along to her
song Roar
be happy
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm just I'm grateful I get to go I met
his majesty to to be
um a few years ago and he named me as an
ambassador to one of his organizations
the British Asian trust which is a
organization that helps fight to end
child trafficking
but the moment that got Charlotte most
excited when her dad Prince William took
Center Stage please welcome to the
coronation concert stage his Royal
Highness the Prince of Wales
yeah the young Royal quickly let her
brother know Daddy's on stage
where she looked at it she saw her
father walking toward out on the stage
and she was so excited like look there's
Daddy you almost can't read what's going
on in her mind she sort of mastered that
sort of Royal approach to public
appearances at a really young age seeing
dad command the crowd like that now
that's a reason to keep roaring
[Applause]
[Music]
I am
yo you're gonna kill me